to the untrained eye  scp-2317 seems to be no more than an old  wooden door but those in the know are  more than aware that we have every  reason to fear this gateway to another  world specifically the door opens to a  desert-like reality where a being known  colloquially as the devourer of worlds  resides when i say resides i mean it's  where he's being held and bound by  ancient chains for now the foundation is  forced to perform complex rituals in  order to ensure that the beast remains  contained so it doesn't escape and  devour us all but there's one big  problem the rituals don't work the  foundation only performs them to give  their own employees a false sense of  security right now the foundation  doesn't know how to keep the devourer  reliably contained what they do know is  his chains are expected to break  sometime over the next 30 years